fais-nous ce qui s'est passé moi je
pense que mon scénario n'est pas trop
fort le 24 novembre dernier des employés
de sony entre au travail ils ouvrent
leur ordinateur et se retrouve devant un
écran noir s'étaient inscrits acte baïji
opi donc une référence à gorzow piste
qui est un groupe de pirates reconnus
on apprend par la suite que cinq films
de sony auraient été piratés dont
certains sont même pas encore en salle
tout de suite après ça on apprend que 47
mille numéros de sécurité sociale
d'employés de ce nid actuels ou anciens
ont été subtilisés comme si ce n'était
pas assez
au moment où le fbi a et se saisit de
l'histoire des employés de sony
reçoivent un courriel où on leur demande
de se dissocier de la compagnie ou
risque et je cite de mettre leurs
familles en danger tout à fait étranger
mais est ce qu'on sait qui est
responsable
les experts en sécurité informé
l'informatique disent que ça porte la
marque d'un groupe qui est très proche
de résume coréen le groupe d'oxford où
on sait aussi que le régime nord-coréen
n'écoute pas très content d'une comédie
qui va sortir s'appelle dit dieu view et
qui met en scène une tentative
d'assassinât du leader coréen kim jong
hoon alors maintenant que les indices
pointent vers la corée du nord voyons
c'est enfin ces deux grandes divisions
la militaire de pirates en corée du nord
au nom des jeunes vous savez qu'on parle
souvent de la menace que les armes
nucléaires nord coréennes pourraient
faire peser sur le monde mais ce qu'on
sait déjà c'est que le bureau 121 lui
fait déjà beaucoup de dommages sont
division écouter de 2000 personnes qui
mènent des attaques régulièrement
partout dans le monde et plus
particulièrement vers la corée du sud
des institutions des banques des médias
sud-coréens font régulièrement l'objet
d'attaqués et de servir tous les pays
dans le monde font seuls les états unis
n'ont fait en iran par exemple avec le
fameux virus le ver informatique stuxnet
en 2010 qui avait infecté des centrales
nucléaires avaient été développées ce
avec une unité israélienne
les chinois sont là avec leur unité 61
39 8 qui elle fait des attaques
régulièrement des centaines d'attaqués
partout dans le monde alors on peut dire
que tout le monde le fait est qu est ce
qu on sait combien il ya de ce genre de
cyberattaques et selon la compagnie mais
khalfi en 2013 il y en aurait eu 200 à
la minute
ce sera la minute ça va en augmentant et
il ya aussi l'ancien vice-président en
fait le vice président de syntec qui est
une compagnie qui fait des logiciels
antivirus qui a dit que maintenant
dorénavant la lutte au virus
informatiques doivent être abandonnées
parce que les équipes qui l'écrit sont
tellement ont tellement moyens ils sont
tellement grosses ces équipes là qu'il
faut se changer la manière dont on fait
cette lutte là et ça fait probablement
en fête s'annonce de très beaux jours
pour les bureaux 121 de ce monde
ils sont légion on va le dire comme ça
vient merci beaucoup matière au plaisir
c'est bien